[Music]
have you ever thought of cloning
yourself or regenerating some of your
organs but being humans we can't just
divide into two to make an extra copy of
ourselves or regenerate any of our parts
if we were some other type of organism
let's say a starfish or a cactus then
cloning or regenerating would have been
possible starfish show a startling
property of regeneration they can simply
regrow their lost limbs to the complete
length on the other hand some cacti can
clone themselves with the help of
fragments which drop off their branches
the fragments can take root and develop
into new genetically identical cacti
these regenerating and cloning
strategies are both employed by mitosis
that we've already seen in depth in the
previous video as we've studied mitosis
helps in asexual reproduction in certain
organisms like in the case of this
cactus plant but in contrast to this
humans along with many other plants and
animals produced new individuals
exclusively through a process called
sexual reproduction the complicated yet
necessary process of sexual reproduction
is the key to species propagation in
higher animals and how is the process
made possible all begins with a unique
process of cell division
it's called meiosis the other type of
cell division in contrast to mitosis and
what exactly is meiosis about let's dive
deeper to understand this beautiful
concept in detail let's begin with the
definition of meiosis first meiosis is
an exceptional phenomenon which produces
four daughter cells each with half the
number of chromosomes compared to the
single parent cell you heard me right
the process gives us four new cells
unlike in mitosis that produces only
two new cells and what could be the
reason for this why do we need for
daughter cells and that too with half
the number of chromosomes just think
about it sexual reproduction involves
both the parents or two cells one from
each parent to be precise now if there
are two cells fusing it's obvious that
the number of chromosomes should be half
in both the cells so that the few cell
will carry the normal chromosome number
now let's take it the other way we know
that the human chromosome number is 46
so if there are two human cells fusing
to give us an embryo then the newly
fused cell will carry 46 plus 46 92
chromosomes this is simply not possible
in nature so in order to maintain the
chromosome number of species it is
necessary that the two fusing cells
contain half that is 23 chromosomes in
number so in order to maintain the
number of chromosomes in the zygote the
chromosome number in the fusing cells
need to be hugged
also the chances of fertilization
increase with more number of cells hence
instead of two making four cells is
preferable in nature this is the reason
why meiosis gives us four daughter cells
with half the number of chromosomes now
since the process yields our cells with
half the chromosome number it's also
called as reduction on division now that
we've got introduced to the process
let's glance at the definition once more
but this time with respect to the
chromosome number meiosis is a process
that gives rise to a haploid cell from
the diploid one now you must be
wondering what does a haploid cell and a
diploid cell well haploid cell is the
one that has a single set of chromosomes
while diploid cell has two sets of
chromosomes that means a diploid cell
has chromosomes in double doses while a
haploid cell has chromosomes in a single
dose so the cells in our body with
46 chromosomes are all deployed while
the reproductive cells are haploid with
23 chromosomes now tell me which are
these reproductive cells that we've been
talking about so far cells with half the
number of chromosomes let's find the
answer in our next video
[Music]